a new North Korean missile test could be
imminent
a report this morning says North Korea
is moving what appears to be an
intercontinental ballistic missile
toward a launch pad the United States is
pushing for the strongest possible
sanctions against Kim Jong Un's regime
over its sixth and largest nuclear test
on Sunday they could target its oil
supply the UN Security Council yesterday
held an emergency meeting Ben Tracy is
in the South Korean capital of Seoul
we're concerned about military conflict
is growing Ben good morning to you so
South Korea does want to see tougher
sanctions on North Korea and that's in
part because they're trying to avoid a
military conflict here which would
almost certainly involve horrific loss
of life here in Seoul which is less than
35 miles from the North Korean border
but just the prospect of a war here in
the peninsula as South Korea looking for
more powerful weapons for the second day
in a row South Korea showed off its
firepower first it was the Army and Air
Force now it's the Navy conducting live
fire drills off the country's East Coast
South Korean president moon jae-in and
President Trump spoke on the phone and
agreed to lift restrictions that will
allow Seoul to increase the explosive
power of its missiles and to buy
billions more in u.s. made weapons the
stakes could not be higher on Monday US
ambassador to the UN nikki Haley urged
diplomacy but warned us patience with
kim jeong-hoon
is thin he is begging for war war is
never something the United States wants
we don't want it now but our country's
patience is not unlimited
a US intelligence official tells CBS
News that North Korea's underground
blast sunday was a test of an advanced
nuclear device but the US government has
not said whether it was a hydrogen bomb
as North Korea claims it also has not
verified whether the miniaturized
thermonuclear warhead in these pictures
released by North Korea is the real
thing or a model
how would North Korea use these Daniel
Pinkston is an expert on North Korea's
weapons program he doesn't think the
regime will launch an unprovoked attack
because that would ensure
it's own destruction waking up one
morning and deciding I'm gonna fire off
a hydrogen bomb at the u.s. just for
kicks we why would you waste your time
why would just blow it up on yourself
North Korea's ambassador to the United
Nations just described his country's
recent missile launches a nuclear test
as gift packages to the United States he
promised there will be more if the u.s.
keeps provoking North Korea charlie Ben
Tracy in Seoul thanks